We will start with.
two
key terms
two key terms
they were of course be other key terms that will be aware of but we will begin
with the word population.
and Sample
We will come across many formulas.
But there will be two variants for each
of these formulas that we will look at.
There will be one formula for this thing. We
call population and a similar formula for
thing called sample.
So
we will have formulas for the for
the set of
topics that fall under population and similar formula that
fall into the set of sample.
I am going to guess that some of you have probably seen one
formula for example standard deviation
and then you come across another one.
And they look different and you go. Wait a minute. I thought this is the formula for standard deviation
that what is this? Probably looking at the standard
deviation of a population and the other example you
were looking at was a popular standard deviation for sample.